Welcome back! Crawley here for our third and final lesson in this module.
Once a project is fully built, the keys are handed over, and the facility is operational, you face an entirely new set of risks.
Inside a modern corporate office or control room sits millions of pesos worth of server arrays, computerized relay equipment, and communication facilities managing the entire business network.
Standard property insurance won't cut it for these highly sensitive systems. We need EI, electronic equipment insurance.
EI is an annual renewable all risks policy that covers material damage from short circuits, voltage surges, and lightning all the way to operator lack of skill or gross negligence.
But here is the real kicker that makes EI an absolute lifesaver for a business: it doesn't just buy a replacement computer frame under Section 1: Material Damage.
Section 2 covers External Data Media. If a power surge fries the hard drives, Section 2 doesn't just replace the physical discs, it pays for the actual cost of hiring data engineers and spending extra manpower to fully restore the lost information.
And Section 3 covers the Increased Cost of Working if a core server breaks down. Section 3 covers the emergency rental fees to hire substitute computer equipment so operations stay completely online and running while repairs are being made.
With Section 1 protecting the hardware, Section 2 saving the data, and Section 3 keeping the business online, EI provides a complete safety net for digital operations.
Lock in these three sections and you're fully prepared to tackle the comprehensive module quiz next. I'll see you there.